.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL THERE.
START WITH THAT DISCUSSION,
KIMBERLEY STRASSEL A MEMBER OF
THE EDITORIAL BOARD AT THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL."
HAROLD FORD JR. FORMER TENNESSEE
CONGRESSMAN.
CEO ENCOLLUSION CAPITOL.
AND FORMER EDUCATION SECRETARY
BILL BENNETT.
LET ME START WITH YOU.
I TALKED TO PEOPLE OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF DAYS.
THEY ARE KIND OF SCRATCHING
THEY'RE HEAD SAYING THIS IS
FIDGET SUE ON THE PART OF
DEMOCRATS EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE
ON CAMERA TALKING ABOUT
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
>> YEAH, THIS IS A VERY HARD
SELL FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO
SUGGEST THEY ARE STRONGLY BEHIND
THE POLICE AND TOUGH ON LAW AND
ORDER.
THE ONLY THING THAT MIGHT HELP
IS SOME TAPES FROM BIDEN FROM
THE 80'S WHEN HE WAS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY AND I
WAS THE DRUG CZAR.
YOU HAVE GOT TO BE TOUGHER ON
THOSE PEOPLE AND LOCK THEM UP
FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME.
I DON'T THINK THEY WANT TO GET
THOSE OUT.
WHAT WE HAVE GOT TO REALIZE
WHILE THE MOST RADICAL ELEMENTS
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WERE
TALKING ABOUT DEFUNDING THE
POLICE OR DISMANTLING THE POLICE
ALL TOGETHER, MOST OF THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE CONGRESS WERE
QUIET.
THE PRESIDENT WAS AMBIGUOUS AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT LESS
AMBIGUOUS IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION.
JAMES CLYBURN SAID WHOA, WHOA,
WHOA THRG IS A MISTAKE BUT HE
DID NOT HAVE A LOT OF ECHOS
THERE.
>> Bret: JUST TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE MONTAGE OF SOME OF THOSE
SOUNDBITES YOU DON'T HAVE GO FAR
BUT HERE THEY ARE.
>> YES, I SUPPORT THE DEFUND
MOVEMENT.
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT THE
INVESTMENT IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
>> I AM FOR DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
>> NOT ONLY DO WE NEED TO
DEFUND, BUT WE NEED TO DISMANTLE
AND START ANEW.
>> MANY AFFLUENT SUBURBS HAVE
ESSENTIALLY ALREADY BEGUN
PURSUING A DEFUNDING THE POLICE
IN THAT THEY FUND SCHOOLS, THEY
FUND HOUSING.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
ONE MORE SOUNDBITE HERE.
THIS IS PETER DOOCY ASKING ABOUT
THOSE COMMENTS TO JEN PSAKI WHO
IS TRYING TO SAY IT'S
REPUBLICANS DEFUNDING.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT WHO DEFUNDED
THE POLICE.
WHEN WE WERE IN CONGRESS LAST
YEAR TRYING TO PASS A RESCUE
PLAN FOR CITIES THAT WERE CASH
STRAPPED AND LAYING OFF POLICE
AND FIREFIGHTERS, IT WAS THE
REPUBLICANS WHO OBJECTED TO IT.
>> HOW IS THAT AN ARGUMENT TO BE
MADE WHEN THE PRESIDENT NEVER
MENTIONED NEEDING MONEY FOR
POLICE TO STOP A CRIME WAVE WHEN
HE WAS SELLING THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN.
>> THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
STATE AND LOCAL FUNDING,
SOMETHING THAT WAS SUPPORTED BY
THE PRESIDENT.
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS WHO SUPPORTED
AND VOTED FOR THE BILL COULD
HELP INBE SURE LOCAL COPS WERE
KEPT ON THE BEAT IN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AS YOU KNOW, DIDN'T RECEIVE A
SINGLE REPUBLICAN VOTE.
>> Bret: OKAY.
HAROLD, WHERE ARE YOU ON THIS?
I MEAN, STRAIGHTEN THIS OUT FROM
A DEMOCRATIC PERSPECTIVE?
>> POLITICS, YOU WILL HAVE
POLITICS.
I GIVE THE DEMOCRATS A LITTLE
CREDIT FOR TRYING TO PLAY A
BRAND OF POLITICS THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT WORK BY SHIFTING SOME OF
THE RESPONSIBILITY.
HERE ARE.
SO FACTS.
THERE ARE SERIOUS PEOPLE WHO HAD
REALLY DUMB IDEAS ABOUT
DEFUNDING THE POLICE A YEAR AGO.
I WAS NOT ONE OF THEM.
I MADE CLEAR THAT ANY PERSON
SPEAKING THAT BOOK DOES NOT CARE
ABOUT THE PEOPLE HE OR SHE
REPRESENTS NOR DO THEY LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY THAT NEEDS POLICING.
I MIGHT ADD ALL COMMUNITIES DO.
GOOD POLICING ROOTS OUT VIOLENCE
GOOD POLICING ROOTS OUT GUN
VIOLENCE AND HAPPENING IN MANY
CITIES.
THE GREAT POLITICAL AFFIRMATION
WE HAVE THIS EVENING ABOUT
DEMOCRATS, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TOP TWO DEMOCRATS THAT FINISHED
IN THE MAYORAL RACE, BOTH WERE
AGAINST DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
ONE IS A FORMER CAPTAIN OF THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND THAT WAS
IN A DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
GET AWAY FROM THIS ISSUE THOUGH
FOR ALL OF THE OBVIOUS REASONS.
I THINK SECRETARY BENNETT IS
RIGHT ABOUT THE POLITICAL
PREDICATE AND YOUR POLLING
CONFIRMS IT, BRET.
IF DEMOCRATS ARE SEEN BEING WEAK
ON CRIME, WEAK AGAINST VIOLENCE
BE IN COMMUNITIES, BIG CITIES,
SMALL CITIES ALIKE WE ARE GOING
TO LOSE.
I MIGHT ADD REPUBLICANS NEED TO
COME AROUND ON THIS GHOST GUN
ISSUE.
BIDEN IS RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
THE OPTICS AND THE MESSAGING
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
SHIFT AND SHIFT DRAMATICALLY TO
GET THIS RIGHT.
>> Bret: OBVIOUSLY THIS ALL SETS
UP, KIMBERRY TO THE 2022 NEXT
ROUND OF ELECTIONS, THE
MIDTERMS.
WE'RE A LONG WAY FROM THAT BUT,
STILL, IT'S A BIG FACTOR.
>> WELL, YEAH, AND IT'S WHY YOU
SEE REPUBLICANS EXPRESSING SOME
OPTIMISM ABOUT THEIR CHANCE
BECAUSE, LOOK, POLITICS IS
LOCAL.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS A LOT.
YOU SHOWED THAT POLL AND PEOPLE
ARE SEEING CRIME IN THEIR
CITIES.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY REALLY RESONATES WITH.
THEY AND ONE OF THE REMARKABLE
THINGS HERE IS WHY IT HAS TAKEN
SO LONG FOR THE WHITE HOUSE TO
COME AROUND ON THIS BECAUSE
HAROLD IS RIGHT, STARTING LAST
SUMMER IT WAS ONLY A FEW VOICES
BUT IT'S THE SILENCE THAT HAS
REALLY HURT THE REST OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND EVEN IN THE WAKE OF LAST
YEAR'S MIDTERM, THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS WHO LOST
THEIR SEATS WHO CAME BACK TO THE
PARTY AND SAID WE DID BECAUSE OF
THE DEFUND THE POLICE ARGUMENT.
WE HAVE GOT TO STOP IT.
AND, YET, IT'S CONTINUED ON.
SO WE WILL SEE WHAT KIND OF
DAMAGE CONTROL, WHERE THIS
DAMAGE CONTROL GETS THEM.
BUT ONCE THAT PEOPLE HAS SUNK IN
TO A LOT OF VOTERS' MINDS, IT
CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT TO REVERSE
THAT TRAJECTORY.
>> Bret: YEAH, FORMER PRESIDENT
OBAMA WAS ONE OF THEM.
LAST WORD ON KIND OF HOW THE
2022 RACES WHILE, AGAIN, WE ARE
FAR AWAY, BILL.
ARE SHAPING UP AND THE
CONFIDENCE THAT MAYBE YOU ARE
HEARING ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> YEAH, WELL, I THINK THE
REPUBLICANS ARE RIGHT TO BE
CONFIDENT, BUT BE VERY CAREFUL.
WE KNOW HOW GOOD THE DEMOCRATS
ARE ON THESE THINGS.
AND REPUBLICANS NEED TO BE
SHARP.
ON THE CRIME ISSUE, AGAIN, THEY
HAVE TO REMIND PEOPLE REALLY
REMIND PEOPLE OF WHAT PEOPLE
ALREADY KNOW.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO PERSUADE
PEOPLE THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TOUGH ON CRIME.
I USED TO DEFEND DONALD TRUMP ON
A LOT OF THINGS, BUT IF SOMEONE
SAID IS HE ABASEBALL, DON'T YOU
THINK?
I WOULDN'T SAY WELL, NO, HE
ISN'T.
YEAH, HE WAS.
JUST SWALLOW IT, LIVE WITH IT
AND SAY W